quand il se passe quelque chose
d'anormal par exemple il faisait beau et
qu'il que ensuite tout c'est en écrivant
la banque les années soixante dix en
polynésie française
les essais de la bombe nucléaire en
plein air sans chaînes de 1970 à 1974 46
tirs depuis l'atoll de mururoa civils
comme militaires n'avaient pas vraiment
conscience des risques
jean-louis camuzat faisait son service
militaire en polynésie au moment des
essais tout à fait sans aucune
protection
je vais être carrément tee shirt bleu et
c'est là la tenue la tenue de campagnes
de rigueur est-ce que les sk qui
casquent dégrade il prévenait des
dangers ou y avoir il faut attendre le
début des années 2000 pour que ces
militaires ou ces civils atteints de
cancers de la thyroïde ou de leucémie
prennent la parole dans les médias et
fasse le lien entre les essais
nucléaires et leur maladie des
associations se forment mais rapidement
elle se trouve face à un mur impossible
d'avoir accès aux dossiers médicaux et
de faire reconnaître leur maladie c'est
pas le seul cas où le docteur
officiellement dit qu' il y à une guerre
rapprochement avec ce qui se passe à mon
goût a poussé travailleurs c'est un
docteur qui le dit et le médecin de
l'armée dit contraire alors il faut nous
expliquer à nous les polynésiens quelle
est la différence entre un médecin
civile et un médecin militaire en
polynésie comme en métropole les procès
s'enchaînent seul recours pour les
associations
finalement une loi est votée en 2010 la
loi morin afin d'encadrer les demandes
d'indemnisation ce texte est un texte
qui a la foi permet à la france de tirer
définitivement un trait sur cette
période de son histoire de reconnaître
les souffrances des personnes victimes
de ces retombées radioactives et qui ont
pu ensuite développé une maladie et
enfin d'ouvrir une page nouvelle mais
90% des demandes d'indemnisation sont
rejetés une désillusion pour les
victimes qui doivent de nouveau
retournés devant les tribunaux pour se
faire entendre
on se rend compte qu après deux ans de
fonctionnement la loi morin de fonction
quand c'est une loi qui ne néglige pas
aujourd'hui on se retrouve au point zéro
c'est à dire
cette loi a depuis été assouplies
aujourd'hui les victimes demandent
d'ouvrir lé droit à des indemnités pour
leurs descendants qui souffriraient de
pathologies liées selon une récente
enquête de dix close cent dix mille
personnes ont été dangereusement
exposées à la radioactivité
entre 1966 et 1974 soit la quasi
totalité de la population des habitants
de tahiti et des îles aux alentours
[Musique]